Speaker 1: If you want a single poll that
confirms that America is rapidly crumbling,
it is a very disturbing series of
recent polls, almost all of which
have Herschel Walker leading. Raphael Warnock
in Georgia, this is such an important race. The
incumbent Democratic senator, Raphael Warnock,
is being challenged by former football player
Herschel Walker. Herschel Walker can barely speak.
He cannot coherently explain his position and the
reasoning for his position on any issue.
He claims to be against abortion, period,
but has now been caught urging multiple women
and paying for the abortions of multiple women.
And if you look at recent polls from just the
last week, you have Walker leading three of the
four polls, Walker plus two, Walker plus five,
Walker plus three with Raphael Warnock up in
one of those polls, New York Times, Siena. And on
average, Herschel Walker is now leading this race.
Imagine the humiliation it will mean to the United
States if Herschel Walker is one of 100 senators.
All is not yet lost. Make sure that you vote.
Other races that are not looking good. The Kerry
Lake race in Arizona where lunatic, big lie
conspiracy theorist Kari Lake who wanted to
secede from the United States at one point,
although now she denies it, she is leading
Katie Hobbs in all of the four latest polls plus
four plus three plus 11 and plus two on average.
Kerry Lake is now leading by almost four points.
Kerry Lake could be the next governor of Arizona.
Vance versus Ryan. J.D. Vance is now leading or
is tied in every recent poll against Democratic
challenger, a Democratic contender, Tim Ryan, for
the Ohio Senate, another very important race. For
a little while, it looked like maybe Ryan was
going to going to be right in there. Now, just
about every poll has J.D. Vance leading. I hope
that if you live in Ohio, you will be voting. And
in Pennsylvania, Senate race Oz versus Fetterman.
We are still trying to figure out what is going
on, but it is as close as it has been. There is
now an insider advantage poll that has Oz leading,
although on average and sadly, these polls
pre-date the debate between Oz and Fetterman. So
we don't really know what's going on. The momentum
has certainly shifted for Oz, as you can see,
as is the red line and just climbing, climbing,
climbing to where it is now a veritable tie. If
you look at the FiveThirtyEight Senate forecast
for who is expected to control the Senate,
it is now essentially tied. What at one point
was. Let me take a look what at one point was
71% odds that Democrats would keep control of
the Senate. That has dropped 20 points and it
is now 5149. This is the lowest point
for Democrats controlling the Senate,
going all the way back to what was it, the late
July summer period. This could very quickly become
a humiliating disaster for Democrats. I hope every
single one of you plans to vote. I certainly do.